non sans prendre
c'est quoi ça c'est une désirs les plus
perfectionnés au monde
c'est une première version du projet sur
lequel je travaille actuellement
qu'est ce que vous attendez de moi j'ai
besoin de vous pour finaliser mon projet
alors votre séjour chez moi sera bref et
désagréable fait tout ce que tu as au
bout dit faire pour ma donné l'ordre de
vous faire souffrir dans le cas où vous
refuseriez de m'obéir vous allez
accomplir ces tests
il est temps
on aurait simplement tu attends que la
police qu'on trouve tu veux mourir ici
personne ne va venir nous sauver
on est au mas
ayoye
julia
julien
que faites vous
je prends des bois
tu dois lui c'est parti reprenez votre
travail immédiatement où vous serez
punis